let's talk deception so you know people
are always fascinated by telling whether
somebody's lying or not like i think
there's even channels on youtube where
all they do is they sit there
and they say look when he did this he's
lying look when he went like this he's
lying look out he's trying to deceive
you by making
doing everything you're supposed to do
to act like he's nervous but he's acting
he's not really like that it's not
really him there's there's there's a
business for that there's books that are
written about this because absolutely
people want to know this so obviously
you've said it there is nothing that's
disputable like there's no you know but
for the most indisputable disputable
unique thing that can tell you somebody
is lying you have to norm that person
it's all individuals you have to norm
that person wow
it's
people
have their own idiosyncrasies yeah and
some people are very nervous in general
and they get totally calm when they're
lying some people are looking all over
the place and they'll
look right in your eyes
when they're lying
there's there's a whole bunch of
different theories that we use we blend
them together in the fbi we don't use
one theory but there's fight or flight
because when people get really nervous
they'll get fidgety because their body
is pumping blood and pumping adrenaline
to their extremities so sometimes
they'll fidget or their hands will go
all over the place they'll they'll fix
their hair they'll adjust themselves
whatever it is
but that is only one aspect that you
look at you have to spend time i told
you earlier when we're doing
interrogations we tell people the
minimum you should spend
is four hours
because the chances of you getting an
accurate and reliable confession
increase 25 percent with each hour that
you spend and those four hours should be
spent
learning about that person
getting as much information about them
and their behavior as possible because
then
when you put the hard questions to them
then you
after having taken in all this
information about the person then you
will be able to notice the changes in
their behavior and those changes are the
red flags those are the areas that you
want to dive into further but again a
lot of people say
micro expressions are absolutely a tell
well in some cases they are in some
cases they are not um the more
intelligent a person is
the more
micro expressions they'll have
the lesser intelligent people
sometimes will will have no facial
indications at all that they're lying
they they their
facial expressions don't give away much
at all
but their behaviors or the words or
their language or how they use certain
words or the changes in words
it's a very complicated thing i used to
teach deception detection at the fbi
academy
believe me it's it's a months long
course it's not something i can just
summarize in one day but i will tell you
this in the fbi
we
actually
believe
that if people
if people
are lying to you
that there are going to be indications
that they are lying
but you have to understand that
individual person before you could ever
hope to know if any person is actually
lying
i love the four-hour rule every hour 25
goes up so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you